so new you're probably the best receiver
in the game there pal thank you but if
you could throw a 70 then your ratings
gonna keep going up what happens if he
throws at 45 if you go down there's risk
here what's going on everybody left go
here in Atlanta to meet up with Mohamed
Sanu the white receiver the strongest
arm in the NFL I want to know how many
quarterbacks he could throw it farther
then and just like a good State Farm
agent Mohamed Sanu was just looking to
help us out
see I'm the Sultan of segues and that's
called branded content it's a little bit
of a reach I apologize but in all
seriousness State Farm is great Mohamed
Sanu can throw far let's get it on
[Music]
yeah so news was good man dude I'm so
excited we're about to do this we get to
show off that arm cannon of yours let me
see how much do you think we got in
there 75 80 so we have ten of the top
quarterbacks in the NFL lay it out on
the field with their longest throw so we
got a light rady Rodgers all the way up
to Patrick mahomes at freakin 80 yards
how many of these guys do you think you
can throw it farther than you've seen
guys on a sideline okay
if you reach Rodgers yeah at 73 you need
successful day right I think you're
gonna pass Brady and Russ right I think
maybe that throw that I saw on Twitter
uh-huh in like the back yards
oh yeah like how far is that how far was
that anything it was pretty far it was
like it was definitely sixty plus but I
had to throw it over at a tree to in a
house that's crazy I also want to see
how fast you can throw it we got a radar
gun great I got it have you ever done
this before no I've never done it right
but I'm gonna try and catch one of your
passes so please don't break my fingers
okay I've done that you broken someone's
big hard oh here we go here we go damn
54 you know that's higher than most
quarterbacks oh my god man I caught no
damn I got so afraid I want to talk to
you what was that
54 I'm catching the next one here we go
Oh 56
you impressed by that catch though
yeah I was nervous you played high
school TV right yeah that's probably
when the arm was the most fluid oh
definitely how far we throw him back
then it was one day it was low Wendy I
threw 84 and 84 yeah the one day wasn't
when he's completely double me bro I can
imagine you weren't too thrilled with
the Madden ratings I came out no bro
power went from a 78 to a 72 they made
their ratings tougher which I understand
but a 72 yeah that's very pretty that's
Eli's huh yeah but now this is your
chance to prove everybody wrong because
we brought in a Madden ratings adjuster
that's the guy that you need to impress
he's gonna just if you want to get your
numbers up sup guys hey I'm Quinn
Oldenburg and Matt in the ratings
performance about me we have you at a 72
throw power which is pretty good for a
receiver you're probably the best
receiver in the game throw power but if
you can throw it past some of those guys
then your ratings gonna keep going up
what happens if he throws it like 45 and
the rating can go down and get there
down it can go down there's risk here
it's time for Mohamed Sanu
to throw the ball deep alright
that's that's a good first throw what
are we thinking right away I mean did
that was that impressive to you that was
pretty impressive I mean he has a
quarterback background out he'd go a
little further you know that you drew it
past Matt Ryan your quarterback he knew
all right throw - here we go
she's fun it I think that's right at 70
Wow it's close 69 I have a little
pressure to add to this if you can hit
70 which you're really close for yard
off we're gonna add package of placed in
about this player could you align that
forth okay just for that I'm gonna get
that for the fence just cuz you said
that because you know I know they've
been asking for tweets all the time so
just for that
[Music]
[Applause]
you know get up get up just for the fame
oh and he's got a play in the playbook
as a quarterback yes I was really
nervous
I thought 69 was gonna be here tonight I
think we're definitely in the 80s now he
came into the 72 throw all right super
definitely definitely an 80s best thing
ever I feel like I'll give a gift
hon even though I was doing all this
giving a kiss I haven't you for no
reason
so barely time to catch our breath
here's first and 10 just outside the red
zone
stop receiver its jones so we were
hoping Mohamed Sanu without throw 16 NFL
quarterbacks at 71 and a half he out
through 28 starting quarterbacks in the
NFL we improved his throw power rating
and it makes me think NFL GM's instead
of looking for a quarterback maybe you
should look for a wide receiver or at
least pick him up and Madam what's up
guys as there's guys to the Washington
risk ass make sure you subscribe to
bleacher report to catch more episodes
from dish to PlayBook with left Co sadly